Good morning, John!
This is going to be my last video before I
go on paternity leave.
John, I wouldn’t say that I’m addicted
to work.
I probably should.
It’s gonna be weird to take a break.
I don’t know what that’s gonna be like.
I haven’t taken a break from doing this
in 10 years.
I started making YouTube videos when I was
26 years old. I'm 36!
Wow. Woah.
But in all honesty, I’m a little worried
about my ability to disengage.
But before I leave you all, I have some housekeeping.
I have made 2 videos that will upload during
paternity leave.
I’ve already made them and uploaded them
and scheduled them.
One is a promo video for VidCon that will
go up as soon as tickets go on sale in Australia,
Amsterdam, and the U.S.
They’re already on sale in the U.S.; Australia
and Amsterdam will be coming soon.
Second, I will be on leave during Pizzamas,
which I feel bad about ‘cause the entire
idea of Pizzamas is that we make more videos
than usual, and I’m gonna miss it.
So I made one and we’re having people cover
me for the other ones, but I wanted to talk
a little bit about Pizzamas this year ‘cause it’s
a little bit different in terms of our designs.
This year, I decided to reach out to a bunch
of my favorite designers on the internet and
ask them for their take on Pizza John, which
has resulted in a very diverse and weird group
of Pizza John designs that I’m very excited
about sharing with people.
I’m wearing a Pizza John hoodie right now
that you can’t buy yet, which I shouldn’t even be showing you.
I’m also wearing a Pizza John design under
here ‘cause I was just making that video.
But you’re not supposed to be seeing these
things at all.
You’re not supposed to be seeing that this
hoodie has that thing.
Oh yeah.
These are all our test print run.
There’s a pile of Pizza John shirts behind
the camera staring at me, literally.
But I’m very excited to unleash them upon
the world, and also I really like the video I made.
So that’s VidCon and Pizzamas.
Also, Project for Awesome is coming up.
I won’t be able to talk about that much
before the Project for Awesome happens, so
get your Project for Awesomeing hands ready,
and if you don’t know what that is, you can Google it.
John, maybe you want to make a video about
that.
I know it’s probably my turn to do that.
Sorry.
I think last piece of housekeeping is that
I will be trying to disengage from social
media, which will be very hard for me.
I’m gonna try to not tweet at all.
There will be people tweeting as me—I think
mostly Victoria—just to let people know
about things that are happening, whether that’s
Project for Awesome or VidCon or Pizzamas
or whatever.
But I like creating content on my social media,
and there won’t be any of that because I’m
gonna try my best not to do it.
So I’ve scheduled some tweets for the future,
just so that there will be something coming out,
and they’re hashtagged #pretweet.
But I can’t come up with six weeks worth
of tweets, so I’m asking you all to help me.
Leave down below ideas for things that you
would like me to tweet, and have them be about
120 characters so we can tag them and also
maybe tag you if you want to leave your Twitter handle there.
And a weird thing happened to me today: I
got this in the mail.
It’s a Google Pixel phone.
Now I want to be clear: I’m an iPhone user.
I have no particular affinity for any kind
of phone, but they did send this to me because
it’s YouTube, it’s Google, and it’s
this related thing.
I am gonna give this to my favorite tweet.
It’s the XL version.
It’s got 128 gigabytes inside of it.
I don’t know how they fit that many in there.
I don’t believe in upgrading a phone just
‘cause somebody sends you a $1000 phone,
so I’m gonna send it to one of you.
Here it is.
I kissed it.
So you gotta leave your Twitter handle so
that we can find you, and I’m gonna put
a hanklerfish on the back of this, so now
there’s that.
And I bet whoever gets this is gonna need
it more than me.
And again, this is not a sponsorship.
I do not endorse that phone.
I know nothing about it.
Choose whatever phone you would like to choose,
as long as it isn’t one of the explodey ones.
And I think that’s it!
I think I’m gonna end this video, and then
I’m gonna go on paternity leave.
It’s a thing that’s actually gonna happen.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.
You’ll see me whenever you come visit?
When’s that?
You coming to visit? You should do that.
You should do that.